und darüber wollen wir sprechen mit
unserem bild chefreporter frank
schneider ja frank razzia bei der
kleinfamilie abou chaker was weißt du
dazu
ja genau die razzia wurde durchgeführt
nachdem wie gerade keiner weise gesagt
hat der sohn verhaftet wurde das war das
erste ziel der ermittler sie wollten
unbedingt den zeit festnehmen den
19-jährigen sohn von arafat hintergrund
ist dass es am 23 september in
recklinghausen zu einer tat kam es
stürmten drei junge männer arabisch
stämmig alle maskiert mit sturmhauben 2
mit schlagstöcken bewaffnet in ein
appartement in dem die frauen offenbar
ihrer arbeit nachgehen dann wurden die
frauen bedroht eine frau flüchtete noch
auf ein vordach und versteckte sich dort
aus panik vor diesen tätern und dann
soll mindestens eine frau vergewaltigt
worden sein dann soll die wohnung
durchsucht worden sein die frauen sollen
ausgeraubt worden sein und dann sind die
täter mit einem dunklen kleinwagen
geflüchtet relativ schnell führte dann
die spur aber eben auch auf den sohn von
arafat nur er war mittlerweile
untergetaucht er war nicht mehr im
ruhrgebiet sondern eben bei seinem vater
in kleinmachnow das vermuten die
ermittler und ist dann in eine wohnung
nach köln gebracht worden und dort
versteckt worden aber die ermittler
waren auf seiner spuren haben ihnen
gestern dort festnehmen können
apothekers gibt es ja ganz viele fragen
sag uns einmal wer ist dieser zeit also
einer der söhne von arafat und welche
rolle spielt der bei den abos ackers
ja derzeit hat hier im ruhrgebiet gelebt
die familie lebt ja verteilt über
deutschland im bereich auch erkenschwick
dort leben viele familienmitglieder der
abu shakra ist dort gab es auch vorfälle
nicht so spektakulär wie man das aus
berlin kennt aber die familie hat hier
auch sozusagen einen stellenwert in
diesen klang familien und der schwager
von arafat lebt auch hier und er ist
auch involviert gewesen in dieser aktion
insofern das ist jedenfalls der verdacht
der ermittler dass er dann ausfindig
gemacht hat wer sind diese frauen wo
halten die sich auf und dann gibt es
noch einen erheblichen verdacht auch der
grund warum gestern die villa durchsucht
wurde obwohl man den sohn bereits
festgenommen hatte es gibt den verdacht
dass arafat dann ins ruhrgebiet gereist
ist von berlin und hat diese
prostituierten bedroht und hat ihnen
gesagt wenn sie gegen sein sohn aussagen
dann geht es ihnen schlecht und die
frauen sollen auch seitdem sehr
unkooperativ sein gegenüber der polizei
und deshalb gibt es auch ein
ermittlungsverfahren gegen arafat und
das lautet auf bedrohung und dann hat
man gestern eben nach beweisen gesucht
nach handys nach datenträger wo
möglicherweise kommunikation drauf ist
womit man diese taten auch noch mal
besser nachweisen können die familie hat
ziemlich viel dreck am stecken man hat
das gefühl die schaffen es trotzdem
immer wieder auf freien fuß zu kommen
was passiert jetzt mit zeit
naja die beweislage ist wohl schon
relativ erdrücken es gibt hier die
aussagen der frau die zwar die täter
allerdings maskiert es gibt einen
mittäter der sitz bereits seit mehreren
wochen in der justizvollzugsanstalt in
wuppertal ein dritter täter ist noch auf
der flucht da hat die polizei drei
weitere junge männer im visier weiß aber
nicht mehr wirklich genau dabei war und
da muss man jetzt die ermittlungen
abwarten wenn natürlich die frauen
wirklich eingeschüchtert sind und
möglicherweise jetzt angst haben ziehen
ihre aussagen zurück oder sagen ich kann
mich doch nicht mehr genau erinnern ich
weiß es nicht genau besteht natürlich
auch hier immer wieder die gefahr dass
es am ende so ausgeht dass auch wieder
zeit auf freien fuß kommt wenn ihm aber
eine verurteilung dann wirklich droht in
diesem fall reden hier von sehr schweren
vorwürfen es sind alles verbrechens
tatbestände schwerer raub schwere
vergewaltigung dann reden wir schon von
mehreren jahren haftstrafe und das wird
natürlich arafat mit seinen anwälten
versuchen auf jeden fall zu vermeiden
also der sohn vom clan chef abou chaker
festgenommen vorwurf vergewaltigung und
dann folgte eben dieser spezialeinsatz
dort vor den toren berlins in
kleinmachnow und allein dass es eine
aufreger immer wieder wenn man da
vorbeifährt diese millionen villa der
abou chaker als danke für das gespräch
bild chefreporter frank schneider